[Music]
uh
all okay yeah we're now live chat
right now welcome members and
the general public to this meeting which
should be an interesting meeting of the
community and resources committee
um first on item on the agenda is
apologies for absence
any apologies received sorry chair no
apologies chair
proper job right item two is the minutes
of the meetings of 29th of june
and the special meetings of 13th of july
and 17th of july
i'm going to go by page numbers at the
bottom
page 4
5 6
7 8
9 10
11 12
13 14
15 16
17. now
are we in well we'll take any questions
or queries first
any questions or queries
none okay can we take it to the
beginning
right counselor bushby
no not me
hi chair um just to propose we accept
the minutes
you've moved councillor dart
yes i'm willing to accept the minutes
but i wasn't there for the 17th of
august
so with the exception of pages 16 and
17.
okay well i'll i'll second them
then we can put it to the vote i believe
right thank you chair councillor brenton
four counselor bright
or penciller bushby or
counselor christy or
counselor dart
for counselor hicks
for pencil hutchins
pencil james
councillor james oh sorry is that james
yep four thank you told you like jones
sorry
sorry councillor lawless
or pencil lock or
henslin mcgoff poor and councillor
wiseman
i'll abstain
right that seems to be unanimous thank
you
we moved to the action list on page 20.
uh who's going to speak to that one
okay the first item um number 17 minute
75
is one that adrian has been dealing with
and that's still ongoing
just comment that i have over the last
few
days received some fairly scathing
comments about the condition of the
torrington
cemetery as it is with brambles blocking
paths and goodness knows what
um if someone would like to speak to me
afterwards i will
inform them as to who's complaining and
what they're complaining about
okay okay thanks chair we will do that
and the second item was a form a
previous
notice emotion from uh council must be
in respect of direct labor force
um harry from in john's team had been
chasing up responses but he was asked to
get responses from a wider group of
councils across the country
i know he's have been having difficulty
getting those responses while we've been
in lockdown
um and we're not going to follow it up
now
councils are starting to work a bit more
normally i think he's had some responses
or john mentioned he'd had some
responses to me this morning so we'll uh
we'll follow that up
and get that information back to the
next committee
thank you steve i noticed councillor
bushby's got his hands up
thank you sir um i just wanted to um
just make the point of
you know why we need to necessarily
get detailed reports you know in
comparing
torridge with our you know with our
nearest neighbor
presumably this is north devon or
something like that i mean
you know if it's if it's a
worthwhile asset for torrance to build
up
um a direct labor force i mean it is i
just don't see why
we need to go outside of our authority
to actually
get the information you know what we
either want it or we don't
and i would have thought our officers
have got enough experience to know that
you know it's either a good thing that
they wish to start off in a small way
and build it up or
or indeed not but you know i just don't
see the advantage of getting outside
shall i respond to that yeah chair the
report that went to
community resources recommending
recommended against
uh doing uh setting up a workforce
um and there's full reports provided to
members for that
and after that whilst that meeting took
place members asked that we look at
what other councils were doing uh we
looked to what other councils were doing
across
devon and reported that back and then
members
asked that we cast the net even wider
and look across the country to see what
other councils are doing across the
country
and that's the piece of uh information
we're now seeking so it was
in response to members questions as to
what other councils were doing
as to why this item's on the action list
okay councillor christie thank you
um i attended the external ovum scrutiny
meeting
a couple of days ago and i did suggest
there that
torres might like to look at taking back
in-house
um the gardening services in victoria
park
can i ask if we're doing this survey of
direct labor which
i suspect wouldn't work going right
across the whole of torridge
but have we looked at uh our parks
taking them
back under in-house because i get so
many complaints
about the state of parks in biddeford uh
because
they've been privatized um and it's been
a complete disaster really
uh are we looking at gardening on a very
sp that's a very specific
in-house development rather than just
look at the whole thing
yes jay if i can respond to that we'll
we'll discuss that as an item on part
two uh later on the agenda chair
okay right
any more comment to action list
or we can move on to item four
which is public contributions
and to that end i've first of all got
alan smith and cathy murdock
um i think i must declare an interest
here
and i'll stand down for dermot to take
over to deal with this speaker please
okay famous chairman i'll take one to
item nine and are we
just to clarify members the public
we haven't nobody nobody there for
public contributions to talk
i item item 4 chair um
chair vice chair it's public
contributions and the first one
is okay mr smith yeah okay we go to mr
smith please who has
three minutes to talk please mr smith
over to you
you're muted mr smith you're still muted
hello can you hear me yes we're gonna
need miss smith
okay thanks all right i'll be back
uh statement by may concerning this
removal of the covenant
um i've asked for this meeting being
part one of this for
the discussion and decision of the
committee for this most important site
to be transparent for western home
residents and other
interested parties the officer's report
fairly and accurately sets out my
company's offer to remove the government
because of its prominent position this
side is very important to the future of
western
planning permission for a hotel is not
welcomed by local residents
nor by the two local councillors council
of laws has properly closed
it was properly close by and the hotel
was far as news
councillor hodgson was elected to oscar
on her promise
of stopping the hotel i agree the site
is too small and unless the number of
bedrooms could be increased to at least
30
is not viable this can only be achieved
by utilizing the council cardboard
this will not be welcome and so on
an alternative use is needed but not
cannot be found
as the site is tied to the government
i'm sorry about this but my stroke makes
me talk a bit funny sorry about that
that's right smith we're aware of your
unfortunate ailments
please continue counselling also
expressed an interest in purchasing the
site
torridge has also indicated which to buy
it back
i've made an extremely high offer for
torrid to remove the government
this would allow me or any other future
owner to consider alternative uses
any alternative use will be subject to
planning
by accepting this offer tdc will receive
a capital sum of 120 000 pounds
for the loss of no assets not selling
anything
this will surely be welcomed by
ratepayers
in the event that this request was
refused i would ask the chair
please ask for a reason to be given and
it should be
called recorded so i can't say well
thanks but
okay thank you mr smith we're now hand
back over to
the chairman mr robert hicks
if fob's not there we'll move on to the
next open speaker
you're there yep back again thank you i
shut up
so now we have john eels speaking on
behalf of the plow arts center
i'm here i hope you can hear me can you
hear me okay
yes excellent my name is john eels i'm
the chair of the plow art center in
torrington
and i'm just here to obviously support
the proposal
that we could garner from your good
selves the 25 000 pounds that
we've been asked to try and find for
ourselves uh but first i'd like to
actually make a couple of thanks
um particularly to steve hurst um i
can't
i can't say hi talk highly enough about
the the way the officers
have gone about uh swift and
excellent actioning of the government
funds to businesses
out and about in turish it has been uh
really very impressive and i have to
send my thanks to them now they probably
don't get enough of it but they
they need to have that thanks because
i've heard from others among
around this country but it's not been as
dutifully well done as he
has managed to make happen so thank you
to them for their
extremely excellent work uh moving on to
plow business
a couple of things to clear i'm not too
sure if you're all aware that
this is still the first uh application
for 25 000 pounds
we haven't received any money yet this
is a continuation of the first round of
talks
that we had in march and this is just an
update
uh on how and where we've got to and
what our plans are
uh you'll obviously have an update
report in front of you which i'm hoping
you've read
which i can actually obviously help you
update even further
um one of the things to say is uh
we still need your money quite simply um
there's no doubt about that and i just
need to clarify
in the update report on section four
and the total funds will be received
from all sources
to help cover the spring shortfall was
in excess of 50
000 pounds and it would seem somewhat
remiss of me to note that only a 1500 of
that
was not forthcoming from the named
funding bodies
of which there is obviously a part of
this outstanding
ask focuses on there not having provided
that money to us
uh this is a shame really i have to say
um and i i would hope you take note of
that
fact um the other thing to mention we
have been open
uh we have opened up uh back at the
beginning of august
and to this point we've had 22 outdoor
performances
which have been extremely well attended
i think richard's following me
he may even give you some numbers there
we've have activities at some times
impossible
that's been open as well we've done
online streaming of various events
and they continue and we're doing some
shows at the big sheep
so although the building itself may not
seem like it's the
plow being open the plow
as an organization continues to actually
provide
cultural events etc uh which is what we
should be doing well obviously
um everybody wants us to do
do that we have been completely
inundated
with well wishes willingness to return
and pledging support um everybody seems
to want to get
get out and have a joyous time with
their friends uh and we would like to
think we can continue that
um and there are clear indications from
the locality
and further afield that hopefully this
will happen soon
and more importantly hopefully they will
get and we will get some support from
the tdc to help towards that
um i'm i'm just going to mention the
burton art gallery or about burton
gallery
it's in it's now in the public domain i
see no reason why we shouldn't mention
it
um there was a point in 2016 when i sat
in a meeting
uh with all the good cultural people of
torridge
and it was declared at that point in
time that the council offer
to the burden was being reduced to
nothing and would be taken on by the
arts council
and we accepted that as being a deeply
excellent idea
very fair absolutely fine uh
to find at this point that the level
playing field that we are struggling
uh to find um with both ourselves and
the burden is
well it's just just very disappointing
um and we hope someone can see some way
of making sure that that playing field
is
evened up across the land we both supply
fantastic stuff for this area there is
nothing i would want to say about the
burton
they do a very fantastic job
there is nothing there's no you and us
or them in us
they we want them to do exactly what
they're doing and better
but we also want to receive the support
that we feel
is probably due but more importantly
that
actually is necessary at this point in
time
and that's where i will leave it thanks
very much for listening
uh and hopefully we'll see some good
news coming from the end of this meeting
thank you thank you mr eels
now we've got richard waltham brown also
speaking on behalf of the plow
hello good afternoon i hope everybody
can hear me uh
john's stolen most of my thunder but i
can reiterate some of the points that
he's
made and and that's fine um yeah we are
not closed at the plough
the the building in torrington is closed
but we've done a whole range of things
and
as you mentioned we've had two and a
half thousand people have turned up to
open air theater events
uh 95 of which have been in torridge uh
at the big sheep and tapeley and uh and
other venues
and we've also done a community
photography project which
captured people's experience of lockdown
which was a lovely thing for them to do
and that's available on our website
and we also did a community a dance film
as well about the different ways that
people have learned to greet each other
during lockdown which is
which was quite innovative uh and a
whole load of other things that we've
continued to do
um we're an asset for torridge and
beyond we're not just about torrington
we're not just about torridge we
encourage people
to come to torridge to experience the
events that we do at 17 different venues
all around north devon um john we don't
normally talk about
the there is a curious thing and in the
past when
we've been told not to talk about the
burton art gallery because it would
either counselors or officers or the
general public will get upset about it
so
uh and i've never quite understood that
the burnt art gallery is a fantastic
resource
and the plough art center is a fantastic
resource but what is kind of unusual
is that a district council uh rather
although some funding is mandatory and
some is discretionary
if there was no funding available for
the arts in torridge we would accept
that and say well that's fair enough
if you can't afford it then that's okay
um but because there is some funding
available for one organization in one
town in the district
then we feel it is kind of our duty to
say well actually
you know we have a hundred thousand
people that come through the door of the
player or get involved online
in the same way that they say they have
two hundred thousand people
who who go to the burton art gallery
every day which works out at
562 people per day if they're open every
day of the year
um so i don't really kind of argue about
figures but the basic thing is that we
there is more than the sum of their
parts that come together
if we and the burton are funded so that
we can work together and ian danby the
new director there he's taking great
strides to work with the community and
he's come out to see us and he's
full of ideas as to things that can
actually help us
help them and help you actually to
provide the aspiration and growth to
create a vibrant culture
that you talk about in this 2020 vision
uh
so we're keen to make that happen we
want to to be a positive contribution to
torridge
uh and we we hear from the people that
support the play on our audiences and
participants and
people with disabilities young people
people who come to events
outdoors and indoors they're all
passionate about it which is why
other venues from across the country
have been to the player to find out how
we managed to operate successfully
in such a small town we so i would just
encourage people and and councillors to
to
um go along with what was sort of agreed
back on the 16th of march
we've slightly fallen short on the on
the the funding from other organizations
mainly because of covid northam district
council would have chipped in i think
but
then the literally the day after it was
agreed then
covid came along and we had to lock down
and so on but this is a time for bold
thinking as ricky s
sunak has as shown you can is and and
after the second world war
the the the response to the government
was to set up the arts council
and all the so many people have
benefited from the organizations that
were funded by the arts council and it's
that sort of
inspirational thinking that we need we
need to kind of go out to help our
scheme or
or something locally which will
encourage people to uh
to make the most of the arts and
community benefits that we bring
so i would just encourage counsellors
officers to work with us
to to really genuinely make torridge a
fantastic place to live work and visit
and we can be part of that
i finished thank you thank you mr buffon
brown
um nobody else wishing to speak and i've
got no record of any statements to be
read out at the meeting is that correct
okay we can move forward to item five
the forward plan pages 21
22. uh
who's going to take that one
i'm trying to study a a list of things
uh for the
upcoming meeting so unless members uh
have any proposals
or any comments
they just need to be voted on
i think we note it and there's no
comments no raised hands
so i assume everyone's got that one on
board
next item is
item six declarations of
interest you all know the score if
you're involved in something
you declare the interest and keep
clear of your zoom meeting
machine i will set you the example on
the next item on the
next but one item on the agenda but
first of all we come to eight
urgent matters i've heard nothing unless
steve has got anything
okay you missed item seven agreement
oh my apologies i write
item seven agreement of the agenda
between parts one and two
it is suggested that items from
fifteen onwards be in part two
uh i shall have to take a vote on that
i'm gonna move straight to the vote
okay you just need a proposal in a
second
i'll propose it
uh council of lords looking to speak
yeah i was actually i put my hand up for
declarations of interest
because for a long time this is rather
puzzled me because it leaves the door
open to actually speak on an item before
you declare
and i think that the wording should
should be amended
to describe the nature of your interest
prior to the item being discussed
just just a note just a thought but it
does
close the door to anyone speaking and
then declaring an interest
thank you chair thank you councillor
lock
i was just going to second the motion
thank you right it's proposed and
seconded
to go into part two on certain items
on with the vote please thank you chair
councillor brenton or pencelebrite
or answer bushby or
answer christy or
penceledart or pencilla hicks
for ansel hutchins or
pencil james or pencil laws
or penciller lock or
pencil mcgough or pencil wiseman
or that's unanimous chair
thank you uh now item eight urgent
matters
uh have you got anything steve i haven't
a chair
i haven't got anything either proper job
we go to item nine where
i'm gonna hand over to councillor mcguff
again to take on because
i act on other items not on this hotel
site for mr smith
okay thank you very much mr chairman and
the item
hello who's that
sorry i chair i have raised my hand
uh but obviously not noticed i wish to
declare an interest
on this item as i previously objected to
the site
thank you very much laws
i will turn off my camera so i can't be
seen to be
influencing anyway thank you very much
council laws
cancer lock you have your hand raised
yes i do
um can i ask um once again the
from the solicitor if a member of the
plans committee
um is at can to sit and discuss this
item
that's two completely separate issues so
if any member of the plans committee
were involved in any decision to do with
mrs smith can you still please join in
this discussion
thank you okay miss dory can we go to
you please just clarification for rose
lock
thank you councillor locking councillor
mcoff um yeah they're entirely separate
issues and
no planning issues are going to be
discussed at all today
um this item is purely in relation to
charge district council as landowner as
opposed to any planning
so um plans committee are fine to
proceed
thank you okay thank you much lock
we're going to go to the uh report it
says to receive the report of the
planning and economy manager
uh the officer will uh present the
report and then we'll take questions
after by councillors
so we'll go to who's taking a report
please
it's me vice chair okay uh stacy over to
you
please and questions after those
counselors please thank you
thank you vice chair um this is in
relation to
the land at the village square westwood
hall
um just to confirm torrid aren't
landowners of this anymore
um the the brief history to the matter
is
that we sold the site to westwood
living in 2014
um previous to that westwood living had
two long leases on the site um a 25 year
lease
and a 99 year lease
westwood living approached district
council
asking to purchase the site from us and
it was valued on the basis that if it
was put on the open market at that stage
any new purchaser would have had to
purchase the site subject to the long
leases
and it was agreed by committee back in
2014
that torridge district council would
proceed with the sale
um to westwood living now part of the
agreement for the sale
was that a restrictive covenant would be
placed on the site
and that restrictive covenant restricted
the use of the site
to the building of a hotel
at the moment the owners westward living
can't build anything other than the
hotel on the site
without coming back to torres district
council for permission to either remove
the covenant
or vary the covenant now
as it stands the owner westwood living
has approached us asking for us to
entirely remove the covenant from the
site
and offered us 120 000 pounds
for removal um that
is in line with the valuation the
district value has confirmed that that
price is acceptable um i should make it
clear that we're not dealing with any
planning issues at all
we don't have any other control over the
site at all it is purely
members need to decide whether they are
content to remove
the restrictive covenant for a capital
receipt of 120
000. happy to take any questions vice
chair
okay thank you stacey just before we go
just one clarity
it was a district value who done the
value to the site you're not an
independent valuer
sorry actually a vice chair i i'm not
sure
who's actually done that i said district
value i'm not sure it's an independent
value or it's a district valuer
i know we've received a valuation and
it's acceptable in terms of the
valuation advice
received okay and the just point of
clarity then
stacy that that's acceptable for tdc uh
if we did use the independent value
to come to that figure yeah i i thought
it had to be a district of value
but i'm not legal so
perspective um we need to evidence that
we're
obtaining best value and and and that's
been evidenced by the valuation report
received
okay thank you very much for your report
um stacy all right i look at the floor
to councils now please
and as a moment i've got nobody there
because i can't see your hand up
no would anybody like to talk on this
report
okay i've got counselor bushby first
please
thank you chair um well vice chair
rather uh
do we have any indication from westwood
living as to
what they would perceive to be
acceptable to build there in the future
you know
obviously it's not going to be a hotel
otherwise he wouldn't be asking for the
covenant to be lifted
but you know is it are we going to see
more flats in westwood
or what plans have we got i think it's a
fair question to ask at this time
i think that's a good question uh
council bush speaker i don't have the
answers to that renee
uh we just as you see before i can't
speculate what's gonna be there in place
but i can just say i don't think it's
gonna be a hotel by reading the report
but
is it um does mr hurst any any further
views on this or any
correspondence with mr smith prior to
this meeting
i'm not aware um i don't know whether
sean or adrian have had
any discussions um but i'm not aware of
any uh future plans
vice chair no i i'm not aware of
anything have been a number of different
ideas talked about over the time but i
think it would be wrong for me to
to guess if you like it what the intent
is okay
so sorry accounts of the bushby a moment
i don't have an answer for you it's just
the
as you see before the covenant okay
thank you
thank you much i will go to council
brenson please
thank you chair uh well a couple of
items firstly we must clear up this
valuation
because it's public money here we must
get an evaluation from the district
valuer
somebody who's plucking a figure out of
the air and saying no that was that's
acceptable
sorry it's not acceptable that we do
have to have something from the district
value it's quite a considerable amount
of money we're talking about here
secondly the question has to be asked as
to whether or not
planning consent would have been given
for uh apartments
to be built there as opposed to a hotel
and the argument for a hotel at the time
was that westward
did need holiday accommodation i mean a
lot of it was stripped out
back two to three decades ago when uh a
lot of holiday
accommodation then became residential
uh it wasn't very good quality but it
was nonetheless that was done there was
an amendment to the local plan
which allowed that to happen so there
was a need for holiday accommodation
of a hotel variety so if that is the
case if
it had been put forward apartments at
the time would planning consent been
given the answer surely would be no it
wouldn't have been
so you know where are we with this okay
council brenter i'm going to go to
um sorry i need to say counselor dory
then sorry mr story
stacy over to you please
just just to come back on councillor
brenton's point
and just to clarify we we have had a
valuation an independent valuation well
i'm not sure if that's
a separate valuer or the district valuer
so
we haven't just pulled the figure out um
uh
thinner um westwood living made the
offer of 120
000 um and the value has said that that
is acceptable in terms of the uplift for
the site for the removal of the
restrictive covenant so
i would would want to put that across to
members
um in terms of the planning and that
would be dealt with via the planning
process and via the separate planning
applications so
today we are just discussing the removal
of the covenant
and and not planning
thank you very much for clarifying that
stacy yeah we're not talking about
planning here this evening
uh i'm going to go to councillor lock
please
yeah i'm just a bit concerned on page 24
the eighth paragraph down
it's got an a4 use of the sites which is
in contravention of existing covenants
and such continued use could invalidate
existing restriction covenants
was i mean i know not talking about
planning but this was a dedicated
officer's decision
and i wonder if he took that into
consideration when he gave
his a4 use for five years
um stacy can i bring you in again please
cause i i was we're not discussing the
planning
aspect of this so can i bring you please
just
i think it's two separate regimes again
um
as far as i know that there's a current
open
bar which is temporary and down on the
site and that was
granted permission by the planning team
but again that's separate to our duty as
landowner
and sorry as ex-land owner and holders
of the restrictive covenant so
the planning team wouldn't be concerned
with the restrictive covenant
that's a property matter and that's
dealt with via cnr
thank you that was your question
councillor
okay i'll move to council christie
please
thank you um i just want to go back over
the history of this a bit because
um i wasn't on the original committee
that granted
the lease uh this is a 99 year lease
now i was astonished when i found out
that
torridge is somehow given a 99 year
lease
i mean that is so exceptional today um
i was however on the committee when this
area came out for sale
it was extremely contentious at the time
and
the covenant was put on because as
council brenton has pointed out the
the whole point of uh selling this site
as a whole was to develop a hotel which
uh westwood actually needs and that was
the only reason
uh this land was sold um
the council bushbeer i think asked what
might go there if it wasn't a hotel well
anyone who goes to westwood ho we'll
know what's going to go there will be a
block of flats probably almost certainly
i can't think what else it could be
um and it does worry me that we we have
had an independent valuation it does say
in our report actually an independent
valuation
for 120 000 pounds now that's a one-off
payment
now if you build a block of flats 120
000 pounds does
doesn't seem very much and i'm wondering
have the officers
explored the idea of overage
because whenever the british trust
whenever we dispose of anything we
always put in
a clause about overage because this is a
prime sight it is extremely contentious
i feel sorry for the westwood home
councillors because they're going to
have to
listen to their constituents probably
bending their ears about this a lot but
this is a prime site
and if it's sold 120 000 pounds to me
doesn't seem very much at all actually
and i wonder if we couldn't go back and
explore the idea of overage
thank you cancel the dark place
hi thank you yeah i'm with councillor
christy there because surely it's
crucial that we know the proposals for
this site
otherwise i i find it mind-boggling that
you can actually put a figure on the
uplift value if you don't know what it's
going to be uplifted
to and again i have
fears over apartments going there
because i remember vividly
the people of westwood hope and the
businesses being up in arms about
apartments so
um i think it's quite crucial that we
don't
actually get apartments there um unless
times have changed
dramatically and i don't live in
westwood house so i don't know but
again the the overreach thing would be i
would have thought a preferential idea
um stacey i'm going to bring in this
point because it's been a few members
now you mentioned about the evaluation
coming from the
the independent valuer there um can you
please explain to the
members howdy
sorry who's telephone is that going off
can we somebody mute the facts yours
please
can we please um have clarity here if we
actually derive to this figure
just for the members of the committee
please because obviously there must be a
reason why it's come to this is
obviously public open market figured
ascertain could you explain that to us
please yeah
just just to clarify and we don't own
the site anymore
um so we can't put an overage clause on
it
we sold the site to westwood living in
2014.
so we did receive a capital receipt at
that stage
uh for the sale of the land so torridge
you've already been paid for that
um the 120 000 pounds that we're talking
about today
is for removing the restrictive covenant
um so when the site was originally sold
in 2014 we received a capital
receipt for that it did have a limited
market value at that stage
because of the two leases on the side so
as i mentioned earlier there was one
lease for 25 years and one lease for 99
years
so that would have meant that the if the
land had gone for sale on the open
market
it had a very very limited value um
because nobody could have effectively
done anything with the site because of
the long leases on the site
when the when west would live at the
living purchase the site
and because they were the leaseholders
the leases were extinguished but that
wouldn't have been
said if a third party had purchased so
on that basis the the district value at
that stage
valued the land on the basis of the
restricted value
because of the two long leases
now the district valuer or the
independent surveyor
has has valued the site but only
for the removal of the restrictive
covenant
so we've already received the money for
the the sale
and now it's it's removal of the
restrictive covenant
um and and that's what we're looking at
so i we can't put an overage on the site
because we don't own it anymore the
only control over the land that we do
have
is the fact that we've got a restrictive
covenant in
to our benefit allowing only uh
the hotel at this at this stage um i'm
not sure why the hotel isn't going ahead
i don't have any other details about
potential building
um but the landowner has approached
saying
it's not viable and therefore he wants a
restrictive covenant
um to be removed and that's what the
valuation is based on so
that's our only control on the site at
present
okay thank you much for that state
thanks that clarity uh cancer wiseman
please
you vice chair um i think this whole
issue
we're gonna get sidelined if we're not
careful under consult all kinds of
details about what should have been and
what shouldn't have been and what you
might do and what you might not do
i think probably mistakes might have
been made in the way back
uh offering it under a lease and then
trying to sell it because that would
have devalued it but that's gone now
uh we've got to be we have to be seen to
be fair and equitable we don't have any
other covenants over any other land at
westwood ho
if the applicant does put in an
application then that will come before
that will come before planning and have
to go through the same hoops that
everybody else has to go through
we've got to be a little bit careful i
think that we're not seen to be too
controlling over this piece of land
which we
don't have any rights over any longer
apart from this i'd like to see it
i'd like to see the site progressing
because it is just sitting there
as a sore thumb at the moment not really
benefiting anybody
my only issue is is this a fair
valuation and
apparently it is so i don't really think
we've got a lot of choice really but to
move forward with this
okay well as from the chat from the vice
chair sorry for
acting as chair i'm going to make the
recommendation that we do accept
the 120 thousand pound as he capital
receipt
to torres district council thus giving
us the public some
actually money back in the purse which
we desperately need during this uh
covert and lockdown period
um it's a fair
it's a fair actually i'll be with a
moment it's a fair price
and let's be honest there's no overage
on the site it's being explained
and i do feel just reading the paperwork
here we can't hold
it's almost like we're homeless holding
us to prisoner you know we can't you
can't do this
it's a fair price the landowner is
actually offered the council
and i proposed would actually accept the
figure 120 thousand pounds
for tourists as a council and i have a
hand that there's councillor darts
cancer dark please
yeah so this was my original question
and i didn't say it
the first time because i actually felt
that the money was
for the um the over
oh what was it the uplift um yes
uplift no not overage uplift
um but actually if it's
not for the uplift if it is
if this money this receipt is purely for
the lifting of this covenant then i
would ask the question
is it actually ethical that torridge
or any council receive money
for doing something thing that someone
wants
essentially that's a bribe is it not
or have i got that completely wrong
money talks
stacey would you like to come in and
clarify the counsellor
i'm sorry i'm not with you today so i
cancelled
dart sorry characters thought i do
apologize stacy can you just clarify
character start that there's not
actually blackmail going on no that that
that was the agreement between torridge
and the
um la um the purchaser at the time
um that the negotiations took place that
that was taken to committee
at that stage of westwood living's
intention
were to um build a hotel and they were
content with the restrictive covenant
being placed on site
um and i think things have just moved on
it it's
uh six years since the sale um occurred
um he was always aware that he would
have to come to
torridge um if the plans were going to
change and
and that's where we are so so no i mean
restrictive covenants are fairly
standard on on sites that was what was
agreed
i i i don't see any difficulty with that
okay cancer bush we got your hand up
please
thank you vice chair um
well i'd i'm inclined to um second your
motion for the for the simple reason
um councillor locke mentioned
the uh the the restrictive covenant
that's
uh in place at the moment uh and it does
state on page 24
that um without further action by the
council this continued operational use
could invalidate
those existing restrictive covenants so
in other words
if they're allowed to continue using the
bar
for another three or four years or
whatever
um the covenant would be unenforceable
anyway
and they would they would then be free
to put in a plan application
um for whatever they feel is appropriate
to the planning committee
so i don't see that torridge are ever
going to do anything to enforce the
um the the use of the site as it is now
whether it's um
you know illegal or otherwise i mean
we've got a particularly good record on
it enforcing anything on torridge
so um you know i should say 120 000
pounds
um we can accept that and
and rely then on the uh on the planning
committee to
do what is the right thing for you know
the people of westfield
thank you okay thank you much guys
bushby well we have a proposal and we
have a seconder
i see you know my hands up so i will
move to the vote so sandra can we go to
the vote please and the
proposal was that recommendation we
removed the
covenant of the land and accept the
receipt of 120 thousand pounds
as a capital receipt for tdc from mr
alan smith of westwood living
so here we go please thank you yeah
thank you cancer brenton against
chancellor bright against
councillor bushby or councillor christie
against councillor dart
against councillor hicks
no sorry councillor hutchins or
councillor james
against pencil and laws
oh sorry
councillor lock against councillor mcaf
four councillor wiseman
oh
that's four for the motion and
six against vice chair
sorry before i move on from this item i
do want a sound reason
of why the counselors have refused the
the covenant there please let me take it
back to mr smith
what what what what are the reasons for
the refusal
and i shan't close this this item until
we get that
uh chair point of view
let's go to what point of order what
point of order
we do not this is normal no no thank you
let's go jeez
okay let's go to officer dory please for
an explanation there
stacy we need a sound thank you i'm
calling in stacey dory please
uh um thank you vice chair members don't
don't need to give her a
reason they either go for the motion or
against and and that's what's happened
here that there's no reason to
specifically um give any further
reasoning
and the motion was was lost vice chair
okay so see my reason of asking you to
do that is clarity that we don't get so
many
any legal implications regardless okay
why should we why should we david
do you say a favor i'm just butting it
for a change mr hicks we move on to your
item mate as you're back in chair thank
you
i don't want to be spoken to like i'm a
member of this committee thank you very
much sir
and wait your turn to be spoken to don't
just butt in have some manners
right gentlemen that's enough of that
we're moving on item 10
financial impact of covid19 an
assessment of the going concern
steve david hayes will be taking this
chair
right
stephen i think it'll move
anybody hear me yet yeah yeah
yeah no problem uh
john i can't seem to share my screen at
the moment i'll try again
[Music]
well we thought that would happen and
those people that voted again
kirsty i says i can't share my screen
while other participant is sharing
do you need to give access to me kirsty
i can see you okay nowadays okay thank
you very much
thank you bear with me one second okay
okay
and nothing's happening oh okay
so what i'm going to cover in my
presentation is i'm going to recap where
we were
in june 2020 i'll go over what's changed
what we're predicting the current
financial position is for the current
financial year and
also what the impact it has over the
medium term
i'll provide some context to the
financial assumptions
in the report and i'll discuss the
just one second i've been told that you
can't can can anybody come back to me
and tell me they can actually see my
presentation
yeah i can i don't whoa i can't
i can't okay
no
i'm getting mixed messages some are
saying they can't and some are saying
they can't
david we haven't got your presentation
on the screen okay
okay
i can see your picture i can't see the
presentation
[Music]
what are you next dinner
thank you very much apologists
colleagues
is it still on the screen yeah okay
i'll start sorry about the delay
so what i'll do is i'll recap where we
were in june 2020
um i'll go over what's changed since
they were last reported to community and
resources
i'll inform members what we're
predicting the financial position is for
the current year
and also the position over the median
term i'll provide some context to the
final assumptions financial assumptions
that are included in the report
and i'll discuss the risks and caveats
to the projections
also i'll i'll take any questions at the
end of the presentation rather than
during the presentation
so where were we in 2020 well
we weren't in a good place we were
predicting reduced
income from fees and charges of almost
1.9 million pounds
we were predicting additional colbit
related expenditure 214 000 pounds
and we're expecting some income
shortfall from both council tax and
business rates of 720 000 pounds
and at that juncture the government had
provided us with 727 thousand pounds of
covid19 support grant
which left us we're projecting a deficit
of just under 2.1 million pounds
and we projected over the medium term
how much that effect on our medium term
financial strategy and we've predicted
the deficit cumulatively would rise from
1.4 million
to 5.4 million so clearly not a happy
time financially speaking
so what we're predicting now we're
actually predicting that we will
break even so quite a change
and there's a few reasons for this we've
had increased central government grant
funding which has certainly helped
there's been a significant improvement
to the lost income from fees and charges
we're still forecasting uh
losses on fees and charges but to a
lesser extent
i'll talk about the council tax and
business rates later on in the
presentation
we've identified some additional covid
19 related costs which i'll talk about
later in the presentation
and of course not every variant to the
budget is
direct related to covid19 and we'll
discuss some of the more significant
ones of them
so so
since 2020 torres has received
additional central government funding of
170
000 pounds for administering the
business support grants
and we didn't really incur a great deal
of costs
administering them grants it was done by
existing officers
and we received a further trench of 129
000
for covid 19 grant pressures
the main difference has been that the
government announced support for council
to compensate them for their lost
income from fees and charges and some of
the rules are the first five percent of
any losses are borne by the council
thereafter will receive 75 pence in the
pound in compensation
compensation will not be paid where
councils have not maximized their income
such as offering free car parking and
the details have only just been released
and currently no income is recoverable
for lost commercial rent income
so there's a little graph there and
essentially if you can see we're
estimating that we'll get another 500
000 pounds from central government
for our loss fees and charges so
essentially from where we were in june
we've doubled the amount of money that
central government is going to um
send our way uh
fees and charges shortfall there's a
little graph there if you can see
car parking was proved we were
forecasting 900 and 2000 we're now
forecasting
600 but the big change has been planning
we're actually predicting a loss back in
june
thinking that the economic recession
people would want to put planning
applications in
actually the reverse has been the truth
we're actually above target
on planning and building control um
investment income from temporary
investment interest from a temporary
investment where we've put our surplus
cash with um financial institutions
that was hit because of the bank of
england base rate and we're still
expecting
to bear some burden on that the
commercial rent income i'll refer to in
a second
and most of the other incomes have
stayed the same
so as i said car parking's improved
significantly and that
i think we all know that's probably due
to the increased visitor numbers so
people who aren't going abroad on
holiday
are visiting our council area in north
devon
the commercial income one is very
difficult for us to predict
because the true position will only
become normal over time essentially
do our tenants in our commercial
properties do they survive
the downturn off because of covid at the
moment we've got arrangements from
people to pay over a
longer period but we'll see
so what did we spend the extra money on
kobe 19 we were spending on
homework in we've had increased
homelessness demand
there was agency backfill on the refuge
department for staff who were isolating
and we gave some support to communicate
grant to the town and parish councils
and we've spent significantly more money
on cleaning particularly the homeless
hostels
and our council offices
um the members are probably well aware
we're in continuous discussions of one
of our major contractual partners
partners to ascertain the impact of
colvid 19. a provisional
sum of two hundred thousand pounds has
been set aside in recognition of this
so council tax currently the collection
rate is four point four percent below
target and the council has only
undertaken very
limited active recovery of its
outstanding essentially
reminders rather than with no confirmed
court dates at this juncture to see
or recover over due council tax
now today there's been a relatively
modest increase in the number of people
claiming local council tax support from
the working age claimants
however furlough is starting to unwind
in that employers now have to make
enhanced contributions to the cost of
staff on furlough and i think the
furlough scheme supposed to end by
october
so we don't know what the full extent of
how the claims for local council tax
support will be affected once the
furlough scheme ends
and we'll estimate the impact of council
tax shortfall on turrage of 252 000 for
the current year
so business rates this has been a
strange year for business rates because
we've got to collect business rates on
behalf ourselves and central government
but the government in response to
coverage announced extended retail
release so consequently the amount of
business rates we've got to collect as
tourist district council
has declined from 11.2 million to like
4.3 million
we're compensated by section 31 grants
for business rates we no longer collect
so in very simple terms
the risk to torridge a business rate
non-collection has declined
essentially because the amount of
business rates to be collected has
diminished significantly
however we are at risk where a business
fails
and this is discussed a little bit later
in the presentation
the current collection rate for business
rates actually surprisingly slightly
above target
i believe this reflects that the
business is actually liable for business
rates and now more heavily concentrated
in the public sector
who actually sometimes actually pay the
business rates up front for the whole
year
we're projecting a shortfall on business
rate income of 84
000. that mainly reflects increasing our
bad debt provision
right so there's a little men at the
bottom and that's
balancing the book so how have we done
this so we've got some other covert
created cost is 100k that we've set
aside
uh for legal book um budget for health
and safety
prosecution a contribution to our
property maintenance backlog and we've
proposing to put some 51 000 to support
apprentice placements
so there's a little table there with the
significant variances up
and down and the things in red uh
the favorable values the things in
notting ready and just black are the
adverse
uh variances but this moment in time
we're projecting that we will actually
break even
for 2020-21 which is probably an
enviable position for many councils
so there are risks and caveats to this
of course we've all seen the increased
number of cases in the news
if there's a further lockdown and
restrictions placed well quite clearly
our income will
fall in terms of things like car parking
for example
i've mentioned business failure where
empty relief when a business
fails empty relief is awarded in the
first instance and that's at a cost to
the council
furthermore businesses and
administration are not liable for
business rates so we don't get any grant
for a
business that goes into administration
and
we can't collect any business rates from
them
council tax we truly don't know what the
extent of claims for local council
tax support will be as the furlough
scheme on end
ends and of course my figures at the
moment make no account of any decisions
the council makes in terms of how we may
support
businesses voluntary groups and other
organizations are going through
difficulties
as a result of colvid19
going concern um the council is required
by its external auditors to make
reference to its ability to continue to
operate as a going concern as part of
the external audit of the 2019-20
accounts the council required to produce
a cash flow statement up to september
2021 however we extended that analysis
up to march 2022
and as you can see from the graph whilst
it's going down
we're predicting well we will have
sufficient resources to maintain our
operations at least up to march 2022
however these key assumptions i've
assumed there's no further
central ground support for covid19 i've
assumed that grant funding levels will
be at 2020-21 levels going forward
i've assumed that we'll increase the
council tax up to the referendum limit
and i've made assumptions about the
level of local cap claims for local
council tax support will equate to three
percent of the total council tax
liability
i've also assumed that the bank of
england base rate interest rates
remained unchanged
so i want to touch on capital at this
juncture so
the council currently has a capital
program of 32 million pounds this
assumes our recent submission for the
future high street application receives
governmental support
and the caf the capital program is
highly dependent upon future sources of
capital funding
the capital program covers up to 2025-26
we currently set aside just over 5
million pounds in reserve to fund our
capital programme
the current funding gap is circa 700 000
but future sources of funding have
different degrees of certainty
so we make a contribution from our
existing revenue buddhist to fund for
example vehicle replacement so we've set
that aside we budget for that's got high
degree of certainty
we get better care funding via devon
county council which is for disabled
facilities adaptations and ecoflex
energy efficiency in homes that's a high
degree search and we only spend
the grant that we get
members have previously um given the
council permission to take out borrowing
primarily for an environmental center a
new refuge depot in other words
and also for the future high street and
also for homelessness accommodation
so you've approved that and we can go to
the pwlb the public works longboard and
get
borrowing at very limited notice
however some of the capital program is
funded from future new homes bonus
funding which is highly uncertain
there's a replacement scheme on its way
but we don't know how we'll be impacted
upon the replacement scheme for new
homes bonus
future capital receipts by their nature
highly uncertain
and grant funding to fund our capital
program well that there is on a
case-by-case basis
so i just want to put this in a graph
for members hopefully it'll
demonstrate the issue on our capital
programme
so let's assume that the future high
street fund is um
approved by central government we'll
have a capital program 32 million
we've got five million already set aside
in the bank so to speak
we will be transferring on a yearly
basis from our annual revenue budgets
primarily to fund the replacement of the
vehicle fleet better care grant funding
which we get from um devon county
council
which funds the disabled facilities
grants and eco flex it
and would say that's guaranteed we won't
spend the money if we don't get the
grant funding
members have a previously agreed
borrowing for us
and there's certain projects in the
capital program which will only proceed
if they're self-financing
and then there's other secured grant
funding so this on this end scenario
assumes that the future high street
funding
is i want approved and will get some
government funding
however the capital receipts the funding
going forward includes a proportion of
new homes bonus funding
and capital receipts which is not
guaranteed
the value of that cash gap i eat the
uncertain
future capital funding is circa 5
million pounds
so the longer inter term in patakovid
19.
well break even in 2020-21 doesn't mean
that torridge isn't facing significant
financial challenges
there's a great deal of uncertainty
regarding the long-term impact of kovid
19 but regional estimates can be made as
more information come to light
it's reasonable to assume there will be
a recession of some impact
which will impact on both our council
tax and business rate income
the provision of leisure facilities in
their current guides will only be
achieved at some significant additional
costs
it's highly likely that the bank of
england base rates will remain low for
the foreseeable future
reducing leading to reduced income from
short-term treasury deposits
it's likely there will be ruptures to
the council's income from fees and
charges
and also partner organizations will seek
support from the council in these
difficult times
so if we could we just really need to
put the champagne on ice for the time
being
so how does this all feed through for
the median term financial strategy
so when we last reported to council full
council in
february 2020 we saw a deficit over the
medium term
cumulatively of just under 1.4 million
the figure to the right
at the top i'm now projecting a figure
of
just under 3.9 million so an improvement
from where we were in um
june 2020 but still a significant
challenge for the council
very significant challenge
okay there's some key points to the
right and
essentially what i'm really saying is
there's a great deal of uncertainty that
the tourist council faces going forward
on a financial basis
um so we've got a recommendation
internal review and scrutiny recommended
on the 18th of
august 2020 that the following monies be
set aside to reserve
namely 110k contribution to the property
maintenance reserve and i will emphasize
that's a contribution
towards the property management rather
than meeting the
full liabilities of property maintenance
that with council believes it has
and also we've had some very successful
appointments
of apprentices who have been a success
in the council and we've proposed to set
a high 51 000 pounds to fund four
additional
apprentice placement new apprentice
placements i'm more than happy to take
any questions
thank you right i'm throwing it open to
the
meeting councilor laws
chancellor laws
sorry chair uh i'm just looking at that
figure of a hundred and ten thousand
contribution
to property maintenance reserve
do you really think that's going to be
sufficient with your experience
well the simple answer to that is no um
but we can't put aside what we haven't
got i mean that
takes us to a break-even position
so he's putting aside he's putting aside
what we've got generated this year
no that is an insignificant figure for
the pressures
yeah you know not just so we get a
comparison
in a normal year say last year
what figure would you have been
recommending there
councilors to be honest historically
what the council has done is set aside a
figure
i believe of 80 000 every year into
property maintenance and at the end of
the year if there's any surplus funds
the property maintenance reserve has
been one of the first recipient of any
surpluses that the council might have
generated
right so we've done it it be truth be
told we've done it
as resources have become available
thank you
thank you no other hands up oh good
which leads me to think that you're all
happy with that report
as done
still silent well
there's a recommendation which says
oh i gotta find the paperwork
um
okay the recommendations on page 40.
yeah
remember to consider the financial
impact
well you've considered it
overview and scrutiny recommended the
approval of two
transfers for property maintenance and
apprentice placements
oh well there's nobody arguing can we
adopt the recommendation as printed i'm
wondering
counselor james yeah i was going to move
the recommendations chair
i think it's very good report it gives a
true picture of where we are
it shows some very good management and
so i'm quite happy to
approve the recommendations counselor
lock
yeah i was second there and i don't
think david accidentally bought again
thank
delete me thank you okay
well it's proposed and seconded
everyone's quiet so we'll put it to the
vote please
counselor brenton
for cancer bright
i think he's absolutely exact
[Music]
can't slip right
i think we might have lost him care
for thank you
cancer bushby
you're a muted counselor bushby
thank you again
all right councillor christie oh
that's the dart
answer dot
john is counselor dot still i don't
think she's i don't think she is
chair i think uh councillor dart has
left the meeting
okay thank you councillor hicks
for chancellor hutchins
or councillor james for
pencil laws or pencil
lock or pencil mcgough
against counsellor wiseman
or
that's nine four chair two against
that seems fine
so we can move on from there to the next
item
which is item 11 the plow
so we hear from the interim
section 151 officer
yes sorry it's me again yes oops excuse
me
i'm just trying to get back onto my
presentation
okay can everybody see a screen that's
gone white yeah
okay thank you so i just thought it's
all in the report just as a quick
background
in february 2020 the plow made public
recurrent funding pressures they faced
of circa 50 000
pounds per annum and the plow started a
crowdfunder campaign which was
subsequently raised 64
54 000 pounds and at the time the plow
was in the process of an application to
the arts council to become a national
portfolio organization
which in theory would allow
contributions towards its core costs
the level of contribution of course
costs at that time being uncertain just
the reason to mention that
is one of the issues that the plow had
was whilst they got arts council funding
they were always for designated projects
which couldn't make any contributions to
their
underlying core costs uh community and
resources on the 16th of march agreed
that torridge would provide funding at
25 000 for the financial year 2020-21
the current financial year
on the proviso the following
organization approached to bridge the
remaining 25 000
funding gap and they were the great
torrington town and lands
devon county council and north devon
district council
the community and resources recommend
that subject to the other funding
requests identified being successful
that the members would approve a single
financial contribution to support the
plow in the financial year
2020 21 or 25 000 pounds to be funded
from the economic development project
reserve and also furthermore community
resources
charged officers of the council on the
management of the plow to ascertain the
the requirement for and the fundability
affordability of additional financial
assistance in future years
and obviously of course the world
changed with the kovid 19 pandemic
live events were cancelled due to
covered knight in effect from the 17th
of march 2020
staff employed by the plow were
furloughed during closed down
and unfortunately redundancy notices
have been issued and a skeleton staff
has been retained
and the plow was attempted to minimise
costs while they were closed
the plow i'll take the point that mr
eels said earlier on the plows remain
closed in terms of physically in the
terms of the theater
but there has been live outdoor theater
events
they've also the plow has made two bids
one to the lottery fund and one to
something's called the arts council
cultural
recovery fund within the bid to the
cultural recovery fund is uh funding for
financial advisors to formulate a
three-year business
plan for the plow in the absence of
funding from the cultural recovery fund
it's not expensive that the plow will
reopen in its former guys until
april 2020.
there will be some there will be some
expenditure associated with reopening
such as
pp equipment protected screams deep
cleaning
streaming equipment that means in terms
of whether you can say transmit
um live theater events from elsewhere
and this
additional expense has yet to be fully
costed
the plow has received or secured the
following funding from the organizations
originally identified to match
tolerance's 25k
contribution so the great origin town
and lands they provided their ten
thousand pounds
devon county provided three and a half
thousand as a contribution towards the
crowdfunder campaign
uh north devon district council did
provide ten thousand pounds but that was
actually a
um a central government support grant
for saint anne's i didn't actually come
from north devon district council's own
resources and the plow
as uh mr hills referred to early on in
his um
presentation at the start received ten
thousand pounds from torrey's district
council in terms of a business support
grant but again that wasn't actually
from our resources that was
was passporting on central government
funding
so the conclusions which are detailed in
reports
that the match funding for torridge's
25k contribution have not yet been fully
secured
it's it is at this juncture unfortunate
uncertain when the plow
in its previous guys will reopen and as
yet there isn't a business plan which
demonstrates the long-term viability
of the plow um consequently the
recommendation is that funding is not
released until there's a business plan
detail on the long-term viability of the
plow
and the officers and the plows continue
to work together to bring back the to
report back to community resource in
detail in the ongoing viability of the
plow
in a postcard covered 19 word i would
like actually at this point to go on
record and say
how helpful both john eels and um
francis lloyd from the plow have been in
terms of formulating this report and
providing information
and being open and honest um in sharing
their financial information
with the council and um it certainly
helps in terms of me
able to put that report together okay
i've got nothing more to say
right thank you
throw it open to members
my hands up
hands up right we've got councillor
bright
first
thank you uh well i think we should um
we should grant the 25 000 pounds for
the plow
that the plow continues to operate under
these challenging circumstances
and still pulling national celebrities
to perform uh even this
uh i think that shows real uh starters
stay in power
on top of that they show uh they they
managed to raise
54 000 pounds on their own
uh and they are only 1500 sure of the
anticipated funding opportunities we
were
asking for i don't you know i i feel
like
they get punished quite harshly for very
slight miss so i don't think that's
quite fair so um i propose that we do
grant the 250
uh 25 000 pounds
to the plow also propose that we
put an additional item on the forward
plan which is to consider giving another
25 000 pounds next september
thank you right now is that a formal
formal proposal in one thing
yes sir is there a second
which includes next year as well
yes chair
right counselor lock
i'm mute yeah i still can't understand
why they have not been able to produce a
business plan
i don't know if david um can ask answer
that question you know
in my view they should have produced a
business plan because they've got to
produce one for their government culture
recovery funded
so i would like to have seen a
business plan before we release this 25
000
yes um i'll
temper this from what i have seen with
um francis lloyd who does the finances
uh
um the cash flow okay so
and it's in the report that they will
have you know they've got sufficient
funds to
operate certainly up to the end of march
but i think where the uncertainty is is
how they can operate going forward we've
maybe reduced capacity at events
i think that's what they've got to work
through and i don't think at this
juncture they've done that piece of work
um i think they just
i'll be stand corrected but i think
francis is a volunteer
it isn't her full-time job she's um
been excellent at providing information
explaining everything in terms of
where they get their sources funded how
what steps they've made to minimize
their cost what liabilities they've got
going forward
but they have not you've correct council
a lot there is not at this stage a
business plan which shows over the next
three years
how they will operate sustainably
[Music]
thank you councillor bushby
thank you chair well i uh
i'm in favor of releasing 25 000 pounds
um
almost unconditionally because um the
you know the grants that they were
trying to um
[Music]
trying to match fund you know they've
almost achieved that but not quite
but i think uh you know the plow is as
important to torrington
and detourage as the burden is to
bidiford and torridge
um it's something you know we couldn't
even contemplate not having
um the player in torrington so for that
reason
you know i'll certainly if it hasn't
already been uh seconded yes sorry it
has council franklin did that didn't he
of releasing this money 25 000.
thank you uh well bear in mind
councillor bright's
proposal was for next year as well
well next year is a bit of a different
ball game but um
you know i don't think things are going
to change that that rapidly for the
finances of the play so um yes i'd
probably go along with that
can i clarify a pointer
for consideration next year so it could
you know be discussed a year so it's not
two lots of 25 off the back
just the one this year and then possible
one next year
for discussion yeah fair enough
counselor coddle honking
thank you i'm not a member of the
committee but i'd just like to speak as
lead member for culture
just briefly and the plow arts center is
a huge asset to the whole region not
just
great torrington but torridge district
and beyond
we must support them as a council and be
fair to cultural organizations across
the district
to allow them all to thrive for the
benefit of our community
thank you
thank you councillor brenton thank you
chair
uh well a pleasure in the second thing
uh the proposal
what we got to remember is that the plow
does need that boat of confidence
if you listen to radio 4 front row on
on the radio the a lot of discussion is
going on now about the arts
and the crafts generally and there's
going to be huge competition for money
from the arts council and various other
funding bodies as well
we'll be up against this area be up
against some pretty powerful
organization
so we need to send a message that our
local community
does support these cultural centers
and we surely must have noticed this
summer the increased number of visitors
here
and they don't just come for muddy walks
across sinjals and heath
or sand castles on westwood ho they want
a whole package of things to do with
their families
and amongst them is of course the arts
so we do need
these as assets to our future economy
as for a business plan good heavens a
chancellor doesn't have a three-year
business plan
you know he's struggling now it's it's
making up as you go along
so i think it's unrealistic to expect
any organization
to come up with a pretty hard and fast
business plan for the next three years
three weeks i'd be impressed let alone
three years
well so
right no one wishing to speak i have one
proposal on the table that will
counselor bright
so it seems to me oh councillor leather
thank you chair yeah well
as somebody who's been to several of the
things that the plow have done over the
years
it is something we should be supporting
and i noticed from david's report
earlier report the financial situation
of torres isn't quite as bad as
it was back in june it's still serious
but it's not quite as bad
there is an awful lot and david said it
himself in the air still
and so to expect the plow to have a
three-year business plan
here and now in front of us is asking a
bit much i think
but as i understood it some of the grant
that they're applying for
presently is to help them enable to put
that business plan together that
three-year plan um i think we should pay
this
i'm glad it's been moved and seconded to
grant
we're only talking about the current
financial year up to the end of march
21 and was six months ago since we
agreed to spend to grant this 25 000
pound
providing the other ones well 23
500 surely we're not gonna we're not
gonna
leave them short just because of 1500
pounds there
we should be paying it we should be
showing support
later on you'll be looking at the burton
art gallery and i think
there's going to be some considerable
saving there if if we go with it
and i think we can well afford to get
give them the 25 000
to the end of march next year thanks
chair
okay no raised hands i'm putting it to
the vote the one motion that's been put
forward by councillor bright
thank you chair cancer brenton
or penciller bright thor
that's the bushby or answer christy
or ensley dart or
pencil hicks four
four councillor hutchins
or anthony james or
councillor laws or penciller lock
or pencil mcgoff or
pencil men oh
that's unanimous chair
right well that went very well
um number 12 renewal of the burton art
gallery and museum
service and funding agreement
who's taking this one that's me
councillor hicks thank you chair
um so for the benefit of members
uh who haven't been around for a long
time uh you might not recall that
back in uh before 2016 the burton art
gallery and museum service was actually
an in-house service
and around 2014 we started looking at
ways
for how we might make that service more
accessible
better more efficient and
a series of reports i think those
members that were around will remember
that there were quite a few
were presented to various committees
looking at options for future delivery
they culminated in november 2014
with the decision by community and
resources to
set up a charitable trust and we then
spent the next 18 months or so
setting up that trust put in place a
suite of agreements
legal agreements and a five-year service
and funding agreement
under which the new charitable trust
would operate
so from april 2016
uh the burton of biddeford has has
managed the service
for us under the terms of the five-year
service and funding agreement
we could and would have liked to have
reviewed this arrangement
earlier but we decided to leave it for
for reasons um for business good
business reasons
until uh last year and then obviously we
were going to present in the spring
this report but covid got in the way and
so we find ourselves now presenting to
you
the proposals for the next uh five year
service of funding
within the report in the financial
analysis section is the
table of costs that was presented back
in
uh 2016 and they they
they bore out so it cost us 874
000 pounds over the first five years of
the agreement
and after a considerable negotiation
with the
the charitable trust department
biddeford um we
have uh completed those negotiations now
and settled on a proposal of 140
000 pounds a year for the next five
years of any agreement should you agree
that
now obviously that that set and the
report is is a significant reduction
um it's a 17 and a half percent
reduction from last year
and over the term uh of the
of the five-year agreement will present
175
000 pound saving on the previous uh
agreement
now there are some risks associated with
the decisions you make tonight
um should members be minded not to
support
of that that figure or a figure less
than that
and there is a risk that that would then
leave the trust unable to provide the
services
that we require them to do because
ultimately the building
belongs to torridge the collections with
it
primarily will mostly belong to torridge
and we pay
the trust to look after those and make
accessible those services
within the report of some supporting
comments from
councillor cottle honking as the lead
member and board members christie and
bushby
uh council mcguff's on the meeting
tonight he was unable to get a comment
from but i'm sure he
can add one if he'd like to this evening
um
but in in simple conclusion i think from
a
uh client officer perspective the first
five years of the agreement
uh have been uh excellent if i'm honest
we've worked in partnership with burton
at biddeford
established a really solid and
well-governed organization
the terms of the agreement have been met
unconditionally
we enjoy a very productive relationship
and i'm sure
members can agree that the quality of
offer
at the burton has improved over the last
five years
um the most interesting part of this
presentation will be delivered by
judith gentry the chair of trustees
and ian danby in a second um and i'm
happy to take questions
probably after that chair if if that's
acceptable with you
okay councilman mcgovern
no thank you very much i'm happy to wait
to the end of the uh presentation thank
you chairman but i'd like to speak first
for me
thank you okay let's have the
presentation then please
okay thank you um i think that's for me
and for me to ask kirsty to give the
first slide
uh so thank you everybody it's some
slightly weird situation where someone's
doing slides remotely
uh for both me i'm judith gentry the
chair of trustees and ian dunby is also
online to share the presentation between
the two of us
so next slide please
okay so what we want to do in the next
few minutes is
we want to share some interesting
information that we think
will evidence our success of the last
five years
talk a little bit about how our funding
model works
um talk a little bit in what we've been
doing in this rather
extraordinary year and how we plan to
extend that for the rest of this year
and sum up with the proposal
that sean's already made so could i have
the next slide please
thank you um as sean's already
indicated uh some of you on the
committee will be very familiar
uh with the presentation that the burton
made at riverbank house some
five and a half years ago now when we
were coming up to
um i suppose the creation of the charity
but perhaps for newer members
this is just a very brief refresher
about what the burden is
so we are a company limited by guarantee
with charity status
we have a separate trading arm which is
called burton enterprises
limited that operates entirely
independently it has a separate board of
directors
um and that operates separately from the
board of trustees
we are accredited by arts council
england which is abbreviated to ace as
most people know that
um so primarily what that means it's a
recognition
that the collection that we look after
on your behalf and that we preserve
conserve
and exhibit and that's over 3000 items
which many of you have seen
is that we have a quality standard and
we do that well
and that we have the skills and the
talent
in the team to be able to do that and
that's um
that's something that is applied for and
renewed every five years
one of our biggest moments of
satisfaction was being granted
npo status in 2017
and as many of you will know um when you
first met me when
i got involved in the burden i don't i
don't come from an arts and a cultural
background
one of my questions was what does that
mean and somebody once described it to
me and said if you had a restaurant it's
like getting a michelin star
you know it's a recognition about the
quality of the work
that you do and the recognition in that
and there are only just over 800
organizations with that status in the
whole of the country
and so when you consider that there's
some you know pretty large significant
organizations in london
i would really want everybody and
they're sitting
listening in onto this to be really
proud of what that means for biddeford
and indeed for torridge to be able to
have that kind of recognition
in terms of how we work as a board of
trustees we have a board currently we
have a board of seven trustees
we have a clearly defined governance
model so we know what the trustees do
and we know what the staff and directors
do so the trustees set a three to five
year strategy
we review that that's a rolling strategy
and then out of that strategy ian danby
produces a business plan
every year that's brought back to the
board for approval
and once that's signed off that's sent
to the officers
to those in torridge so the officers in
turidge
have sight of our three-year strategy
and
our one-year business plan once that's
approved
ian takes that through with the team to
implementation
could have the next slide please
so undoubtedly the burden's thriving and
i would hope that everybody
on this committee and indeed all of
torres district councillors can take
pride in the sense
that you made the right decision in 2016
by transferring that from your own
management to
the charitable organization under the
terms of the service and funding
agreement which
we're coming to to talk about now which
is the new proposal before you this
evening
so i'm going to hand over to ian and
he's just going to take
through i suppose what could best
describe as some
uh examples of just how we are thriving
so over to you ian hello everyone um
i'm going to just tell you a bit of put
a bit of meat on the bones in terms of
maybe our visitor number so if we put
the next slide up that would be great
thank you
so as you can see at the moment we're in
a very healthy position
as of last year where we had 203 000
visitors to the burton
um and just to put that in context
that's roughly the same amount that
visits
the icon gallery in birmingham or it's
certainly
it's about 25 more than nottingham
contemporary in nottingham
so we really are punching above our
weight and in terms of our visitor
numbers what we're really looking at is
about 60
of those being local and a further 40
coming from locally nationally and
internationally including
substantial number of tourists and i
know
council brenton mentioned that it's
about offering a whole range of
um experiences and this is an area where
there is limited access to arts and
culture
so as you can see that we really are
punching above our weight
next slide please
one of my key passions is really about
making sure that
the burton isn't just a resource for
biddeford and that we
go out and about take the collection
well with us where we can
but actually undertake outreach and
engagement in schools
undertake workshops and we as you can
see have substantially increased that
over the last year um with outreach i'm
sure many of you have seen the burton
art box the horse
converted horse box which has been at
westwood ho in ecuador
uh in the park here and at torridge so
we really would i mean unfortunately
we're not in a position to be able to
take that out at the moment but we
certainly want to see that in increasing
in future and
the good news is that we have our first
school coming in as first school visit
coming in next week
next slide please
one of the key elements of what we do
offer is the tourist information center
in our staffer
incredibly professional hugely
knowledgeable
and although many people have seen a lot
of this now being done online
as you can see we're getting over 10 000
visitors specifically for the
tourist information each year now a lot
of that
is because a number of the of the
visitors that we have are elderly
and are really used to the type of
services that the old tourist
information office do
but it allows us to be able to be in
touch with other cultural and
tourist venues to find out um what's
going on
more roundly and offer the best advice
and guidance we can
to people that are visiting and my one
aim often is to try and turn those
visitors to the tourist information
service into arts lovers
and culture branches by um offering them
the opportunity to come into galleries
or visit the museum
next slide please
as you can see we have a substantial
number of active volunteers
and many of those are working with us on
the ackland and edwards collection
cataloging and undertaking translations
of letters
they're also there to support us in our
events and also work with us
on digitization of the uh the rj lloyd
collection
and making sure that that's open and
accessible by
phd students or students who are really
interested in the heritage
of what is actually a world-class
ceramics collection
um when you marry that with the
christian household collection those
students said there's a lot of
pieces of work which we show and look
after
and the access to that online or
physically and in person
is a huge benefit this is one of the
five
best collections of ceramics um in the
country
in terms of its breadth so we really
should be very proud of how we deliver
that
so also we do very local things we work
with
five five or between five and seven
schools who wants to undertake work
experience here
so we offer those opportunities because
people are very interested in
becoming uh engaged with the creative
and cultural industries and there are
very few
opportunities as i've said before um and
also we work with two young people who
have life-changing disabilities
and um we've you know anecdotally been
told how much how much of a difference
that has made
to their lives
next slide please
as was mentioned before mpo states well
my background really is
that's our use i worked for 10 years for
the arts council as
head of visual arts for the whole of the
west midlands
and as judith said it is quite an
accolade a gallery of
this size it's relatively small but has
mpo status
and our officers have noticed how much
we do if you imagine
the scale of opportunity that the arts
council involved with
and how much money and investment goes
into the larger galleries
we're seen as being hugely good value
for money
um and they were keen to talk to us
about potential uplifting funding
because of the range of work that we do
and uh our impact
more broadly um obviously
they used to not want to invest in an
organization where it's
reducing having funding reduced so
one thing that we do need to be
conscious of that is if significant
reductions beyond this
where it may actually affect investment
overall in the
in the area but this bit comes from our
um
this quote came from um our
arts council head um who obviously
undertake a significant
um investments in us but also in how we
produce the work
and deliver that recently we've had
outstanding reports
for the quality of the vikki lindo
exhibition which many of you will have
seen
so next slide please
i thought i'd put this up because i
think it's proved really how much
and how things have changed for the
organization um
um obviously it's always useful to put
the michael morpurgo quote in
um that never hurts but just the sort of
things that we've been you know whether
that's a holiday maker coming to see the
show we've got at the moment
or actually people um visiting and
seeing what an absolute gem
this organization actually is and how
the collection has inspired so many
people
um to go on and become ceramicists i'm
sitting in a in the gallery upstairs
um amongst an exhibition of local
ceramicists pauline and gizando
and their work their original work was
actually done in a youth project that
was run by the burton and
devon county council 15 years ago
so these things have bought fruit i'll
get to julia
thank you next slide please
okay um so the next couple of slides uh
councillors i thought you might be
interested just to see how the shape of
our overall funding is developing over
four to five years so that
um we continue to grow into this
continue to be this really healthy
organization
so the top pie chart represents the
first year of the charity in 1617
and the second pie chart clearly the the
current year
that that we're in so i'll draw your
attention
to two things on there so if you look at
the orange section
then that represents what we've talked
about of arts council
uh funding so that represents how our
successful application for npo
and to those has brought in a
considerable amount of funding
and that we would hope and as our
intention to grow in the next round
i thought you might also be interested
in looking at the
grey sector because you will actually
see that that's
shrunk and you might be thinking that
refers to donations and legacies
so how is that how is that happening
what's the burton doing what's happened
there
so in this example that you see in 1617
we were fortunate enough to receive
quite a substantial legacy um but as you
will appreciate
um one never knows when these are going
to arrive
if they're going to arrive and what the
value of those the amount is going to be
of of that generous donation that
somebody might have left us in a will
and so therefore that in that particular
that was a one-off
um but i also thought you would find it
interesting to draw to your attention
just the changing faces of donations
generally
so you'll all be familiar with you know
the idea of putting some money in a
donation box or in a tin when you leave
when you leave somewhere but all of the
evidence is that that is now
substantially reducing and that's that's
the there's several reasons for that but
um one to quote is you know we are
becoming
increasingly a cashless society and
particularly in the current pandemic
where we're being
encouraged to use cards rather than cash
the likelihood of us
having a couple of pounds in a pocket
and to those to put into that
is reducing so that's the first reason
why we're seeing and that's a trend that
we think will continue
and the second reason is there seems to
be evidence that people
are becoming um
in a sense they wish to contribute to
something more specific
than an overall money in the box so
we've had more success in fundraising
when we present to the public or to the
organization
a specific cause so for something uh to
those
to restore a work of art or for example
in acquiring a particular new collection
which we know will enhance the work that
we do
so we we see that that's changing and in
fact probably in the next few years
we'll probably look at the way that we
report that because
to represent the way that life is
changing with for example an increase in
online donations
but as well as where we've been and
where we are i think
the trustees andy and have have a model
of where we think
our robust funding should be so if we
could have the next slide and ian will
take you through that
so the next slide again shows clearly
where
we anticipate the funding coming from
there's a slightly enlarged element from
arts council
and really what we're trying to do is
support
a balanced portfolio of funding from
many different sources the simple idea
of not putting all your eggs in one
basket
and our own income at the moment is
quite substantial whether that be from
the shop the craft gallery
or room hire or and the events that we
work we run
um and there's certainly at the moment a
huge well
certainly at the end of last year and we
hope in future there's a huge demand
for workshops and master classes which
we will take full advantage of
one of the things that we're committed
to doing over the next few months
is developing more income applying for
grants
for the museum section of the offer
um and really updating the type of scale
of opportunity that we have
and i know a number of you have already
been supported with that idea
and how we're doing but we really feel
that um
that because of this the range of work
we do and the breadth of the work that
um that we feel that we are able to sort
of diversify our income model
um through the means i've suggested on
there
so next slide please
so what have we been doing so um
there's nothing more heartbreaking uh
than a gallery with
no population and no visitors in it
and and it was a you know what the march
the 20th will never be my favorite day
of the year ever again
but one thing that we were committed to
doing was making sure that the people
that we would be working with were not
disadvantaged so we continue to hang the
school's exhibition even though we were
closed and we filmed it and we put it
online
we continued to do quite a lot of online
activity and we reached roughly
83 000 people through all our social
media
many of which were engaged in planting
seeds sending in photos
making paintings i know many of the
counselors here received
some seeds through the post for us we've
been focusing on
developing activities like the talk
series we're doing called good
afternoons
which was really about doing something
that people felt very comfortable with
so if really forward planning and
rescheduling our activity we've had to
move a number of exhibitions
and obviously develop the exhibition we
have on now from from basically from
nothing
we've obviously undertaken quite a lot
of maintenance i'm sure some of you will
see that
the buildings have a good lick of paint
and looks at its best
next slide please so we opened on the
fourth of july
um which probably will be one of my
favorite days of uh
being here for all time because we were
one of seven galleries and museums to
open on the first day possible
and that will always be a proud moment
for me
and the team here and since opening
we've had 12 and a half thousand
visitors come through the door
physically
which has been great and obviously as
i've said we've gone on to
undertake activities we've done some
talks and music sessions
which we're continuing on throughout
september in the park
which again thank you to the team there
for being so supportive of that
but unlike many organizations we felt
that we needed to open up
get visitors back in get people engaged
in the arts and they have been hugely
grateful
and thankful for that and we've been
hugely grateful and thankful for their
response because although we've had
roughly at the moment around 70 percent
less visitors
they've managed to spend less but not
substantially less
than they were spending last year and in
fact in the craft sector we probably
exceeded last year
but the impact on our reserves has been
substantial um
we've lost we've had to invest 30 000
pounds and our income over this period
based on last year's figures is a loss
of 110 000 pounds
can we have the next slide please
so as you can see the figures um after
we've reviewed them because
our business numbers are increasing
slightly so actually we're about 70
claim on last year's figures at the
moment but we've substantially reshaped
the business plan and model
and we've been trying to work with
people who are trepidatious about coming
into buildings
and have made the building safe and a
one-way system that actually works
so visitors have felt really quite
content with the changes that we've made
next slide and over to judy thanks ian
um just to sum this up my counselors i'm
aware you've got a very long meeting
on this evening i hope you're not
flagging too much and we haven't
taken this on too long um we did
recognize of course
that um we needed to acknowledge the
extraordinary times and the finance the
impact of the pandemic
on uh tdc's finances and be realistic
in the financial request that we we were
making
as sean has indicated um we've been uh
discussing this topic for
uh to bring us to this point for about
10 months
i don't need to repeat what the request
is
the paper sets it out very clearly but
as you can see it is a significant
reduction
and it would not be right if i didn't
say that this is going to be challenging
so how do we match the fact that this is
a significant reduction
and we match that with our ambition so
um the trustees have set together to put
a model together
and we are going to be looking at what
we can grow what we stop
hold or maintain so next slide please
so this work is already underway and i'm
sure
that you will understand that our first
priority is
don't go backwards for those of you
familiar with the burton
and familiar with some of the things the
quite difficult decisions that
the governing body has taken certainly
in the first couple of years of the
charity
will know that that came as a price and
so we're all absolutely determined
councillors that we are not going to
lose the momentum that this last five
years
those has brought we're going to be
ready to grow again so it's going to be
important we're going to make sure that
we can turn that hot tap on
so the minute anything changes for
example in terms of social distancing
becomes more relaxed
and we can offer more things then we're
going to be ready to do that we're not
going to spend weeks doing that you know
we want to be able to be ready
to say if something changes on the
monday we can start doing it on the
friday it goes without saying that you
would have an expectation of us that we
continue to be
excellent value for money for torres
district council
i personally take that as a very serious
responsibility
as do the rest of the board of trustee
trustees
we've referred to the fact of our
ambition so we need to be strong enough
and to those to be able to not only to
retain that npo
and to those which we clearly are but
also as the statement from arts council
said they're really
interested in increasing our
contribution providing
that the sum that we're um putting
forward to those tonight
and to those is demonstrated that we as
the trust and that's the mix of
us as the governing body and ian and his
team others can deliver onto it
you know and finally for us uh to
continue to be that leading venue
in the north west and to grow you know
to continue
um to be the inspiration for
this for arts in north devon
could i have the the final slide please
so in summary um we hope that we've
evidenced for you
uh those during this presentation that
the decision was correct in 2016
we've exceeded those expectations we are
financially stable
and we receive critical acclaim we
recognize however that in the current
financial situation we need to play our
part
and we need to be realistic in funding
for the extended agreement
and as set out in the paper the request
is for 140
per annum which is a 17 and a half
decrease on this current year
um so uh thank you chair shall i pass
back to you
to take any questions
right thank you uh councillor mcgrath
has had his hand up from the beginning
thank you very much mr chairman uh what
i'd like to touch on the burton art
gallery the
presentation there was absolutely
fantastic i really enjoyed that
and you've just shown that you've worked
so closely with torres district council
the lead member and the board members as
well
um you know it's an absolute asset for
biddeford and torres in general
um i was unable to give a comment on the
report due to work commitments
but like i'd like to touch on the mpo of
the burton itself
i mean it's so important within torridge
that we actually
support you given you do so much
for the economic growth of in the area
which is absolutely key and
predominantly biddeford in general you
know but that footfall of people coming
into bid of it itself
is the regeneration at this time
absolute needs and we can't afford to
lose an asset like the burton
i've been there several times myself
took a little boy around there you're
absolutely authorities enjoys it enjoys
the cafe there
um this is an asset for arts and
cultural hub
within the center of torridge i closed
it at center storage
give i only with bias being there north
ford member one of them
you know the burton has done a fantastic
job and you've shown
how proactive you are actually giving a
reduction as well
now that to the taxpayer's pocket is
well it is fortunate what we need to see
and i do back
100 this is key in the times are in
just shoot we do have value for money
and
my true opinion is the burton art
gallery is value for money
therefore i will uh move for we approve
the recommendations
on page 55 as here so and i'd like to
thank
mr kearney and his team for the report
they produced this evening
so i'd like to propose we accept the
recommendations and i give to burton
100 support and i wish you all the best
in the future
thank you
thank you chair um well i think in this
day and age it's
you know really refreshing that uh an
organization
um the size of the burton art gallery
are coming to torridge with a with a a
significant reduction in their request
for a five-year
service agreement um you know i think as
council mcguff says you know we're
getting very good value for money
uh i think it's an ad
i think the uh you know the burton have
done a terrific job
during the the shutdown period because
of kovid
i've been there several times myself um
and it's
incredible to see what they're actually
putting on there so i would at the
second
uh comes from gulf's recommendation that
we fully accept
the recommendations as shadowed on page
55.
thank you counselor lock
i'd just like to thank ian and judith
for a very positive and professional
presentation tonight and it makes a
refreshing change for an organization to
come forward with a reduction
in their funding applications um
although i live as council watson says
out in the sticks
i know that all my um schools in my ward
have visited
the burton at various times and have
come away learning
much and i would like to fully support
as well but i do have one query and it's
like query on slide number nine
in the presentation
it says the arts council would be
interested in the burton applying for
more funds than the next round of nbo
i mean how much money are you talking
about there do you know
and how would it affect your you know um
money from torridge then okay so i'll
ask the
i'll answer the first bit counsellor
lock and uh there may be in or b
are those the second so um
the first point of when the window opens
for applying for npo
is um you're required to
to show what any existing funding
agreement is in place so that's what we
would
there's been showing so we would be
saying under this scenario that
uh we have a five-year funding agreement
of 140k
and to those for five years
they the uh arts council then sets
certain bans
and i'll hand over to ian those are
those we don't
the short answer is um we would be
negotiating with them about how much
that could be but perhaps ian
you can just expand on that a little
yeah so i think
one of the things that the arts council
said is because of the scale of
our audiences whether that be physically
in the building or
in the outreach program that they would
be happy to support us
um i mean obviously they have to weigh
up there's a slightly different
situation but they'd have to weigh up
but somewhere in the region of 40 000
something like that i think will be
something that they would be keen to
talk respect that's what figures have
been
muted right thank you
okay no one else wishing to speak
we come to the vote on it i have only
one proposal
i have to say that the presentation we
have received tonight
has made me a lot happier the ward i
represent
has very little sympathy for the burden
and would be quite happy to see
it disappear i think but the quality of
the presentation we've received tonight
makes me think a little different right
we'll go to the vote
yeah you've got a couple of hands up oh
couple come up now councillor christie
yeah thank you mr chairman um i have
actually seen people from buckland
brewer in there
oh a few have a beard um
can i just point out one thing because
um i don't know how many
councillors are aware that uh
when the burden was uh presented
to biddeford by its two founders mr
burton and mr coop
i believe it's a covenant was actually
put in place that they cannot
charge for entry the only way they can
actually raise money
is through their shop or they can
actually charge for
special exhibitions so they're in a very
different position
from uh museum from um swimming pools
and
the plow and other places like that so
they do
need this external funding i can only
echo what my two other ward members said
uh
councilman mcgough and councillor bushby
the excellent presentation
and uh the burden is extremely important
to torridge it's even more important to
biddeford but
it does have a reach throughout torridge
and
i think we ought to see ourselves
support this
wholeheartedly support the burden thank
you
cancer pennington thank you chair um
as you know the chairman we share the
same award
i must say fantastic presentation i was
lead member for culture and leisure for
three and a half years under the last
administration it's been great to see
and this presentation sums up all the
hard work the board has done down there
i covering the same areas you yourself
chair
took extra time to ask about the burden
in the sticks
and my most furthest award and your most
fair this ward is
east and west pathford from the burton
and they were very much supportive
of the burton so there is a lot of
support not only within biddyford
but within the wider area of torridge as
well
so my findings is very different to
yours chair
thank you okay
be that as it may i think we talk to
different people perhaps
perhaps we would talk to each other one
day chair
right we'll go to the vote thank you
chair
councillor brenton or
chancellor bright four
henson bushby
hutchins
i believe council hutchins is left
thank you john councillor james
has counselor james left john
sorry yeah she has yeah yeah
thank you counselor laws
council of laws is left as well santa
thank you one two three four five six
seven eight nine
that's unanimous with the nine members
thank you chair thank you right thank
you
i now have to say goodbye to members of
the public on
the behalf of the committee thank you
for your attendance and watching
but we have to move into what's called
part two
which is where the press and public are
excluded
because we have to deal with certain
financial matters which
we have to keep quiet about
so i propose we move into part two now
is there is
councillor bright
yeah i'll second that chair thank you
can we put it to the vote please thank
you chair
cancer brenton or
councillor bright or penciller bushby
or councillor christie
canceller dart or
cancer hicks or
counselor hutchins has not come back
okay counselor lock or
handsome mcaf
unanimous chair thank you
thank you i'll just go i'll just stop um
live streaming to youtube and could i
just ask um one of our guests who's
still in me
in the meeting to leave please
and counselor james is just trying to
rejoin